[Music]
welcome everyone to our today's webinar
the topic of today is b-cell cell
culture
and we want to give you advice how you
can upgrade your b-cell culture
so let's directly start
so here i just have a short overview
what we are going to talk about today
first i'm going to give you an
introduction on b-cells in general and
why the b-cell culture is so important
and maybe also so tricky
then i will hand over to henrietta who
will give you some yeah background
information on the technology and why it
is so important to have good tools for
cell culture
and then in the end i will give you some
application examples on how you can
standardize your b cell expansion so
let's directly hop into the topic
and start with the introduction on the b
cells
so as you probably all know
b cells have very important functions
in the immune system so there are
actually quite many so they do produce
antibodies and have a memory function
they produce cytokines
they play a role in wound healing
also in antigen presentation and also an
important topic is the th1 th2 cytokine
balance
they also regulate dendritic cells they
play a role in tumor immunity and then
also of course co-stimulation is a very
important topic
so they are actually in general two main
subsets of b cells so the b1 and the b2b
cells
so the b2b cells are actually the b
cells what that we usually call b cells
it's the largest population of b cells
and it has a part in the adaptive immune
system
so also we have here the b1 cells the b1
cell is like more yeah innate like
immune response it is a t cell
independent
it has like in general the same role as
other b cells they make antibodies they
also act as apc's antigen
cells
but they really produce more a natural
type of antibodies they participate in
maintaining of the tissue homeostasis
as well as the immune defense against
much pathogens but their repertoire of
visa receptors or antibodies is more
yeah polyspecific polyclonal
so this way they also bind to cells
antigens and can play a role into an
autoimmunity
and they also protect the body mainly
against microbial antigens
and in this b1 cells we have two main
subsets
db1a
cells and the b1 b cells
and now we look into the b2 cell so now
from now on i will just call them b
cells
and how they are developing
so mainly the b cells develop in the
bone marrow so from the progenitor cells
we have pro pre-image obesity then
transitional bases and then in the end
the mature b cells
and in the bone marrow there's a lot
happening so we have the video
rearrangement so
the rearrangement of all the genes until
an actual functional b-cell receptor is
formed
there are also positive and negative
selection is happening what is really
important so that this signals are
mainly antigen independent and also the
negative selection is really important
to have tolerance for the own body of
course
then in the next step the b cells the
mature b cells are mainly dividing into
follicular b cells and marginal zone b
cells
that can get activated so here we have
the follicular b cells that are getting
activated
those follicular b cells are mainly
circulating in the blood
and after the activation they build a
germinal center
and then affinity measuration is
happening so proliferation maturation
apoptosis and also here the stimulation
of t-cells is happening so that we
always get like you know the best
highly fee and really good antibodies
that we want to have
and out of here we have like the memory
b cells that come out
that can be activated up on antigen
contact that respond really fast and
have very high proliferation
rate that then um
are differentiating into plasma cells so
we have either a long lift plasma cells
or plasma blasts that are then turning
into
other short-lived plasma cells that
produce antibodies like crazy but an
activated b-cell can also directly
go into the status of the short-lived
plasma cells to produce antibodies
faster because of course this germinal
center reaction takes a while
also we have the here the marginal zone
b cells
do you really defend
against blood-borne pathogens and they
have more uh t cell independent plasma
cell production so they don't undergo
this german center reaction
and then where they get activated they
also build plasma blocks that then turn
into plasma cells
you see there's like a lot going on in
the b cell development and there are
many different b cell subsets that we
have
also we have the regulatory b cells this
is a very specific and very yeah unusual
subset of b cells so it's still unknown
where the origin actually is coming from
so some people think that it's like in a
specific
pathway and i think that like you know
with the right stimuli actually each b
cell can turn into a regulatory b cell
they have mainly immune suppressive
functions so they see secrete cytokines
like il-10
and they could be generated in vitro
through
the addition of inflammatory sickness
but there is still a lot of studying
ongoing
on this regulatory b cells
so here you can see
why it is actually so hard to culture
the b cells because they really need
several stimuli to really activate the b
cells
and this is like you know really hard to
mimic in in vitro because a reward is
like you know a lot happening with the
help of the t cell so yeah first the
contact of the b-cell with the b-cell
receptor to the integer
then in the next step you also have the
t-cell that is then binding to the
b-cell so we have the mhc representation
of the antigen of the b cell then the t
cell can bind with the t cell receptor
to it and then it presents the cd40
ligand to the b cell
and then of course also cytokine
production of the t cells is happening
so they produce a lot of different
cytokines that then bind to the cytokine
receptor of the b cell surface and what
leads them to clonal expansion and
differentiation what really depends a
bit on which cytokine mixture this t
cell is actually giving and which
signals this b cell is getting so and
this mimic this is like really not so
easy
in culture conditions because they like
the friends of the t cells that giving
them the health
so that was it so far from my side from
the introduction part i will now hand
over to henrietta so that she can
explain you the technology background
thanks for handing over susanna
um i will try to cover today a bit the
technology part of the cell culture and
would like to work with you together
on
factors first factors influencing the
reproducibility inside culture and then
focus on one of those factors more in
detail and try to show you how we can
use this factor to increase the
disability in our cell culture so let's
have a look together
first of all the cultivation can
influence the reproducibility in your
cereal culture meaning the media you are
using also the supplements like vitamins
you're adding also how you're sub
cultivating the cells mean are you
trying
in case of bacteria in cells are you
tryptonating the cells how lung
trautination goes or are you using
equitase
and one of the biggest factors
causing variability are animal derived
components like the fcs and variation
between the different batches
then we also have the cells [ __ ]
influencing the reproducibility in our
cell culture
in terms of cell lines
the age influences the outcome as cell
lines that are cultivated for longer
time periods can display different
behaviors or results as phalanx
cultivated for a shorter time period if
we are working with primary cells
for sure the donor variability will
influence our result but also the way
how we isolated the cell and how we
produce the procedure is will have an
impact on our outcome but also when
you're sawing cells this can influence
the cell culture meaning that time i
need to throw the cells or the freezing
medium i use
and how they are stored if they're
stored in liquid nitrogen at -80 and
this can also impact your
results and then the experimental setup
will have an impact meaning the timing
of the experiment and if the
experimental changes in between this can
also impact but one factor which is also
really important is the setup meaning in
terms of reagents you are adding and
variance between the different batches
and this is one point i want to discuss
with you today with more in detail these
are the cytokines
we are adding to our cell culture for
expansion but also for the experiments
because
cytokines can also have a great impact
on your cell culture and within the next
slides i would like to show you how this
why this is and how we can reduce this
variability so
if we are having 10 vowels of a side
decline different batches and add of
each while 10 micrograms to an essay and
for example have a look at the
proliferation of the cells
do you think it will have the same
effect have all batches the same effect
on ourselves if i asked like that the
answer is quite obvious no is not as you
can see in this example down there we
will have five current batches with a
low activity
causing less
proliferation and we have cytokine
batches with a high activity causing
high proliferation and this example to
my mind shows nicely that weight
does not equal the activity for
cytokines meaning if i use the same
amount of egg or cytokine it can have
different activities so why is this why
is weight not it does not equal the
activity for cytokines for example if we
think about how proteins or recombinant
proteins like cytokines are produced
here in the example of e coli
they are denaturated for they need to be
denaturated first
and then
need to be refolded but during the
refolding process we will also have
misfolded or re-aggregated proteins
which are done not active anymore
so if we have a look now at our example
for the cytogram with the low activity
most cytokines are misfolded and thus
not functioning whereas with the
cytokine of the high activity nearly all
cytokines are correctly refolded and
dysfunctional and i think this example
shows
nicely why cytokine dosing
should be done according to the activity
of a cytokine and not using weight only
so to be able to dose to the activity
let's first think what biological
activity for cytokine means for cytokine
the ed50 value is defined as the
concentration of a cytokine that is
required to induce half of the maximal
activity and it's given a nanogram per
milliliters to make it more easy to
more comprehensive you can have a look
at the example below
here you can see a dose response curve
where different concentrations of a
cytokine were used
and at one point the response is a
plateau
that's the maximum response we get and
if we take 50 percent of this response
we will end up with the ed50 value
and this 8050 value is then taken to
calculate the biological activity in
units per milligram
using the shown formula how can you get
this activity in your lab either you
decide you do in-house testing which
means you will have to test every lots a
lot by yourself or you have to supply it
doing the testing for you but in this
case you need to be careful because a
lot of suppliers only state the minimal
activity of the cytokines meaning they
guarantee you that the cytokine will
have a certain activity but don't tell
you how active this lot is
for example they guarantee you that the
cytokine has an activity of two times
ten to the sixth units but in fact the
batch you can get can have two times
more but also 10 times more you will not
know it and with this we can help you
with our premium grade cytokines because
there we state you and give you in the
coa the lord specific activity and then
you can use this lot specific activity
to those cytokine in your experiments
and do not need to do the lot testing
anymore so if we're using units to dose
in our experiments we should think about
how reliable these values are for
example if i use one cytokine and test
it in two different essays the results
will not be the same as the dose
responses are influenced by the cell
lines and the used assay condition
meaning the units are only relatively
for example if one supplier states we
used one essay and the other supplier
states we used another essays those
values are not comparable
how does it look like if the same essay
is used
yes
this makes it more comparable
but
if i take one cycle time and test it in
the same essay at different times or in
different labs the outcome can still be
different as that those responses are
influenced by self their cultivation and
essay condition and that that's the
reason why
essays should be calibrated whenever
possible ideally for this is a who
standard taken but such standards are
not always available if you use a
standard for calibration you also test
it in the essay and then normalize the
results of your essay to it
this will give you the calibrated
activity
and reduces the variability
if this is done you can compare the
result
and i want to show you within this slide
how calculation reduces the variability
and the image on the lower left from
in-house data from us we can show how
vandalization can increase the water lot
consistency and then also from
external results where different
labs tested
one cytokine
and normalized it to a in-house standard
all that used the same batch
whereas on the lower image also
the same batch of cytokine was used in
all labs but it was normalized to
international standard and you can see
how the reproducibility in the results
is increased when an international
standard when the same standard is used
in each lab how can we find out
if the essay was calibrated or not
this is usually stated on the web page
of the supplier or in the data sheet and
for us also in the certificate of
analyzers
there you can always see is the
calibration to the standard and iblc if
this is stated the essay was calibrated
if we now have our new calibrated units
that we can use for our essay we need to
decide on the optimal amount that we are
using in our ethics
this is ideally tested one time in-house
in the left to define the optimal amount
to avoid all this
load to load testing
it's also often done that just a high
amount of cytokine is taken
which leads to oversaturation of the
experiment
but this over saturation can be avoided
if you know the units on the biological
activity of your cytokine and have
tested once how much how many units you
need to add to your experiment this is
shown on the example on the right if you
over saturate you can simply take 1000
units
and you will end up in the platofic
but instead of 1000 units you could also
use 100 unit and would get the same
result
meaning you could save reagents and does
money if you dose according to the unit
that's the reason why it's important to
know what you get and besides the cost
effect of oversaturation and also has
another dark side
oversaturation can have a serious impact
on the cells and the experimental
results
as you can see here with the different
or some publications given as an example
where it is shown that the concentration
or the unit influence the results and
can have a negative impact if you're not
closed correctly
to sum up
how we can support you with increasingly
reproducibility in your cell culture
are our premium great title plans as we
provide you with a lot specific activity
you know what you get thereby you can
increase the reduced visibility of your
cell culture save time and reduce costs
and besides this we offer a lot of our
premium grade cytokines also as next gp
cytokines which facilitates the seamless
transition to the clinical research
and with this i would like to hand over
back to susanna that she explains you a
bit more in detail the standardization
of the b-cell expansion
perfect thank you very much henrietta
so now we know all the details what are
the backgrounds so what do we need to
know to really do a proper and good
cultivation and now i'm going to give
you the insights into the b cells so
there's a very standard protocol on how
you can actually cultivate b cells
so you use the b cells of course mix it
with cd40 ligand proteins and il4
and by this
you only get low expansion of b cells
but we actually made an optimized
protocol so this we have also available
as a kit so the b cell expansion kit for
human b cells where we actually have a
mixture of different things that are
important for a high expansion so we
have to optimize cd40 ligand multimeters
across linking antibody and also il4
inside and why is this so important so
actually
you see here on the picture that the
cd40 ligand multimeters do not bind to
only one cd40 receptor no it's binding
to several one and that really makes
sense because when you imagine that
usually the t cell would give this
signal would give this help to the b
cell it's not touching the b cell i'm
just like you know one side and one
receptor it's touching them on several
sides and maybe also other other t cells
are coming and helping from the other
side so this really mimics the t cell
help that leads to high expansion rate
as you can see here so you really have
like your pure b search in the beginning
and then the in the end you end up with
like you know highly expanded and
activated b cells
so here i give you some details so you
will get up to 10-fold expansion of the
bss in v2 within 14 days
it is a standardized culture system with
a very efficient b-cell activation so we
are here we also implement the max
premium grade cytokines
so now you know why this is like so
important because in the henrietta
explained that to you
and you also have an efficient
activation of the b cell so you really
have an increased
expression of the activation markers
like cd86 and mhc2
also we preserve all the subsets with
the kids because it's really important
because you want to have all of them in
the culture so the subsets are
distributed similar to actually the
original fraction
and we also tested the visa expansion
kit in a modified version with il-21
instead of if and we observed an earlier
onset of activation and the
differentiation into more yeah mature
and switch status but i'm going to go
into details right now so that you see
the data what we actually measured
so here you see the expansion rates
so here we have the tenfold expansion
within 14 days with the normal b cell
expansion kit but it's already really
nice but when you add then the is21 to
the culture instead of aisle four they
have to be clear
you see that the onset of of expansion
so is that a bit earlier so you already
get the ten-fold expansion
after ten days and then after fourteen
days both kits are more or less
comparable
but we actually tested all of them here
i'll show you the example for cd86 and
mhc2
for
both protocols and you really see nicely
here that with the
standard b set expansion kit cd 86 is
highly expressed after 14 days of
culture
and also mhc2 but with the modified
b-cell expansion with il-21 you actually
see already a high extra expression of
mhc2 on the b cells already on day seven
what is like you know going to yeah it's
a bit lower than after 14 days but you
really see that the b cells are nicely
activated
and then of course i told you that all
the subsets are like distribution is the
same as the original fraction so that we
preserve the subsets
so here i just wanted to show you how we
actually analyzed this so we actually
cultured the b cells for 14 days as i
described you before
and i just did the flow analysis
afterwards on the cells
and we first
gated the dot plots on
unstimulated pieces so this is likely
just for example how the unstimulated b
cells look like
excluded debris and doublet and gated on
a viable cd19 cells
and we actually selected and here for
the subsets a switch memory b cells
a non-switched memory b says an ifb
cells by analyzing for the markers igd
and cd27 so that you have the subsets
here switch memory non-switch memory and
knife b cells but we also checked for
plasma cells and plasma blasts
with the markers cd38
and cd 138 which you can see here and
here
so by this we actually found out
that the memory plasma cells have a
similar distribution to the original
fraction so here you can see the b cell
expansion kit and next to it
unstimulated cells
in the culture after 14 days and here is
the original fraction on day zero
and you see that actually the knife b
cell population goes a bit down but it
is just due to the fact that they have a
shorter survival rate in general
so they usually die after a while
and when you now have a look here on the
right side the modified b-cell expansion
protocol with il-21 it looks a bit
different so you really have more
switched memory b cells and even plasma
cells are popping up here so you really
see that we have a more
mature more switched status of the cells
when you're using this protocol
and for this you probably have to like
you know understand a bit like what
different cytokines are interested so we
also did cytokine secretion patches and
i first wanted to explain you what
actually the cytokines are going to do
so what we think they're doing so we
have io6 that's a
pro-inflammatory cytokine that's
actually secreted by activated b cells
so kind of a marker for activation
when we have il-10 we talked already
about this in the very beginning that is
like this is immune regulatory cytokine
that is actually
balancing the immune system triggering
antibody production and you know really
like
it's a counterbalance for inflammation
and we also have if what is like the
activation agent so we taught you
already that usually a gh2 cells
reproduce them to activate the
b cells but also the cytokines active in
the new naive cd4 t cells to get
differentiated into th2
responses
so in here we did the cytokine secretion
patterns for our expanded b cells
so with the visa expansion kit with
using human il4 we have high levels of
course of il4 and il-6
on day 7.
this level increased then over the time
on
day 14 what you see here
and then for this kit
the production of ielts 10 is then
increasing but of course
you know here you have to be like a bit
careful to say that actually like the
b-cells are producing the i-4 of course
they're not producing the i-4 because
it's rather the fact that we give it
into the culture because when you now
have a look
on the results with the modified
protocol with il-21
you see that ex that we have no
i-4 in the culture
so that really like gives us a hint that
the i4 in for the other protocol is like
the iphone that we gave into the culture
but you really nicely also see that we
have a lower secretion of il-6 and it is
a secretion levels of il-10 on day seven
are much higher than the other
protocol and this makes sense because it
has been reported that actually
they are yeah in line with the yeah
plasma cell differentiation because i
already told you it's important for the
counterbalance to the inflammation
triggers antibody projection of course
where rich cells produce the antibodies
here it's the plasma cells
um and then on after 14 days with this
protocol actually we have like lower
level of uh cytokines
and yeah more or less low level of l4
but of course we have also other b cells
stimuli so we don't only have like you
know this one protocol this one kid that
you can use we also have like
a lot of tlr ligands slt3 ligands we
have many many cytokines so henrietta
already talked about that so this is
available for human and mouse
and also we have different sizes
different versions so to say of the cd40
ligand multimeter that you can also
nicely use for your culture protocol
and
yeah most most of the cytokines and some
also also of the ligands are also
available as gmp great what's really
nice
so now i want to just give you a short
side note on actually this tlr
antagonist
so there are many different classes of
the odms
and for b cells mainly the class b or
the ends
and the class podns are interesting
and there's like a slight difference in
what they're actually doing to the b
cells
so actually by this um
class b or the ends you actually have a
very low interferon alpha production but
a high il-6 production so high
activation and proliferation of the b
cells
and also we recognize that in
recombinant cylinder lines we have high
nf copper b mediated signaling processes
with the class p or the ends it's a bit
different so there we have high
interference alpha production and also
high ir6 production
and it's like more only mainly a more
strong b cell activation
but for the nf kappa b mediated cyclical
recombinant cell lines it looks the same
as for the other tlr antagonists
so now we already at the end
and i hope we could show you that we can
really help you to improve your b-cell
culture we offer a lot of different
pieces of demoli so if you're interested
in just like you know look on our web
page there are a lot of different things
that you can maybe use we have the
b-cell expansion kit with a reproducible
and really standardized culture process
that preserves the subsets
and gives the efficient activation and
proliferation of the b cells and with
the grade side to clients you can never
go wrong because you have to lot a lot
consistency what reduces your cost
enhances the reproducibility and allows
standardization of your culture
now we're already like you know at the
part where we thank you
for your attention
you